this decision
will not have an unexpected U-turn from
the man who was once the second richest
person on the planet
gothabadani cancel a share sale or
follow-on public offer after raising two
and a half billion dollars the business
tycoon says it's because stock prices
have been fluctuating for me
the interest of my investor
is Paramount
and everything is secondary
hence to insulate the investors
from potential losses
we have withdrawn the fpo The adani
Group shares have been in a week-long
meltdown it started when American
Investment firm Hindenburg research
accused it of quote the largest corn in
corporate history alleging stock market
manipulation and accounting fraud
Hindenburg is a short seller which bets
against stocks and makes money when
share prices fall adani group has
questioned its motives calling it a war
on India the report has shattered the
group's credibility media reports
suggests two Global lenders are no
longer accepting adani bonds as
collateral for loans India's Central
Bank is also reportedly asking Banks
here to give details of their exposure
to adani companies
opposition parties are demanding a
Judicial inquiry and a debate in
Parliament
it is the money which
is hard-working Indians have saved it's
their lifetime saving and their hard
work which they've invested
for their future they say adani has
benefited from his friendship with prime
minister Narendra Modi the conglomerate
has built major infrastructure in India
last week it brought the Haifa port in
Israel for more than one billion dollars
there are growing calls for improving
corporate oversight you know Indian
conglomerates have over the last 10
years have really become Global players
and while they have become Global
players the the regulatory you know
systems in India and let's say and in
the U.S or in Europe there is a gap so
Indian regulation has to catch up and
has to has to evolve a far more
transparent system
Gotham adani is no longer Asia's richest
person India's stock market regulator is
reportedly examining the canceled share
sale pavni metal al-jazeera New Delhi